Jurgis usually when directors make a
period film they're actors and they're
department heads are asked to release
steep themselves in the history go for
authenticity I understand you instructed
your cast and crew to do the opposite
and sort of let go of the expectations
of the period is that right and if so
why yes I think I'm not sure if I
instructed them but I encouraged a
different approach I think it mostly
happened not through conversation or but
we had a rehearsal period that lasted
for three weeks and I think during that
period I try to instill a different kind
of approaching their performance the
text how they saw each other how they
saw the the film itself Rachel what went
on in that rehearsal period what kind of
things did you do am I allowed to say of
course it's been told many times it was
more like a rehearsal for a play in that
we were company of actors it was the
court of Queen Anne three women three
men and we played kind of games where we
spoke the text whilst following certain
rules that Jurgis gave us a physical
game which took your mind off the line
so it was about three weeks of getting
to know each other again to know the
words getting to know each other's words
but not ever doing any acting we didn't
do we didn't say the words with as the
characters with emotion see see the
story of this movie actually starts
quite some time ago this script came
across your desk many years ago can you
tell how it came to you and and why it
was so challenging to get it made how
much time have you got
it it came to me and completely out of
the blue by someone who'd never written
anything before in their life and she'd
found this story and she Bree searched
it and found the the letters between
Queen Anne and the Duchess marver and
Abigail was involved as well and it was
just one of those stories that wouldn't
quit and you know it's fantastic story
of betrayal and survival and to
heightened of course because it was all
taking place in the world stage and it's
a true story
and I think part of the problem whether
were number of sort of obstacles not
least of which period films were not
very popular back then at all they were
sort of tainted nobody wanted to get
near them plus there was sort of the
same-sex sexuality that was going
through it and I think a lot of these
financed ears were not moralizing about
it they just thought we don't have a
debt we don't have a number graphic for
that so we're not going to go near it
anyway that's kind of what some of the
challenges were Edie you were not
daunted by it and you it was you I
believe who thought that your ghost was
the right person for this can you
explain why well I don't want to take
credit for that actually I'd it was I
think all of us and where we had this
project which was a period drama I think
we had an instinct that we wanted to do
something a bit unusual a bit different
with us and I think it might have been
my colleague Lee who met Jurgis and
exactly sure who met who when but
dogtooth was out at that time and we
were already struck by it it was
brilliant film and Jurgis responded to
the notion of it read the script and
joined us and I was ten years ago
so I think you started 20 years ago we
joined ten years ago we met you probably
nine years ago or something like that so
yeah it's been yeah quite a while
Nicholas it's also kind of fun for once
to be able to ask the male actor about
working in heels and wigs and
Rouge so tell us how your your costume
and your hair and makeup informed your
performance I mean they were they always
do but obviously when you put on
costumes like that that sounded designed
and the the wigs were big and and
Nadia's costume design it's just
something that transforms you and then
you have to kind of step up to the plate
with those things that fairly
uncomfortable heels at times yeah quite
a big guy to be wearing those but it was
just wonderful I mean I like Tony's
writing was such fun and then to put it
in that environment with the freedom
that Jurgis gave us through that
rehearsal period and and how he the
environment he creates it was a great
experience yeah yeah the language in the
script is is great it's so beautifully
written I mean any of the three actors
if you could talk a little bit about the
dialogue was it difficult to learn was
there a sort of tempo you were going for
I think by the end of the through this
three week rehearsal period we kind of
knew we knew all our lines and each
other's lines we just said them or so
many times but no we weren't going for
anything in terms of rhythm or we just
over to you we just what did well we
felt a little in the moment and we just
did it it worked with each and that's
and it just I didn't just happen just
like that ma you're the two other women
you're working with had worked with you
are ghosts before Olivia Colman and
Rachel had work with your cos you were
sort of the newcomer in the trio did you
beforehand get any sort of tips or
advice about what this experience might
be like or how to prepare no I mean no
you ever we talked about it but there
was no it's unexplainable really so yeah
but also I was lucky because I had met
Jurgis I mean almost two years before we
started filming so we had had like we
we'd had dinner a couple of times I felt
like I was comfortable with him and then
got getting to know Rachel
Olivia through the kind of rehearsal
process when I you know was able to
spend more time with them it was it all
felt very comfortable and warm and but
no there's no real prep to the jurgis
process Nargis one of the things that's
unusual in a good way and again because
there's nothing unusual nothing very no
the way you shot it is unusual can you
talk a little bit about the decisions
you made about lenses and camera
who cares about lenses miss Rhoads this
room cares poor people
well I it's it's it's it's mainly
something that I've been experimenting
with I think my last few films it's
something that I enjoy and in particular
this in this film I thought that the use
of wide-angle lenses in these huge
spaces with these very few people in
them
that's the trickster position of the
lone figure and the huge space and how
the space was even distorted it felt
quite claustrophobic in generally kind
of reflected you know a lot of a lot of
the dynamic in the film and the themes
of the film and the juxtaposition of
those wide shots with extreme close-ups
of the actors that kind of clash was
also quite interesting and the
combination of the movement which
connected Kat the various characters and
you wouldn't know the time cut from the
one to the other the fact that this base
connected them and the wide angle lens
kind of enhanced that because as you
move the camera the whole room changes
in the perspective changes changes those
some of the reasons why I felt like it
was fitting for this film what do you
think do you feel any sort of
contemporary relevance with these these
three female characters three
complicated layered beautiful fierce
cruel exciting funny women yes yeah I do
I think that it was an unbelievable
to see a script and a director so
passionate about bringing that to life
that was about three women who are so
fully formed and fantastic they aren't
just strong which rachel has talked
about that a lot strong females they're
also not to take these out of your mouth
you should say it fragile and so many
other things they're they're beautifully
written and yes I think that if that's
contemporary then which I hope it is
then then yes and funny very funny well
thank you all very much for being here